good morning mr chairman and good
morning members of the house state and
federal relations committee for the
record my name is sharon carson i have
the pleasure of representing senate
district 14 comprising the towns of
hudson londonderry and auburn and i have
for your consideration this morning
senate bill 360 relative to the national
guard education benefits this bill
allows for members of the new hampshire
national guard to transfer their
national guard tuition waiver benefit to
an eligible spouse
when one member of the family serves in
the military we all know that the entire
family serves as well
this bill aims to be a recruitment and
retention tool for the new hampshire
national guard while extending benefits
to spouses
thank you very much mr chairman i'm
going to conclude my testimony and you
have
the general here from the national guard
who will be able to walk you through
just exactly what this is going to do so
i appreciate your time this morning
mr chairman members of the committee for
the record i'm major general david
mikulitis the adjunct general to new
hampshire national guard
so first i want to explain to you the uh
the why behind the what
so why why are we doing this and what is
um you know the purpose behind this
the new hampshire army national guard is
obviously a small state we're a small
state
the 17 smallest states for force
structure the size of our guard the less
than 3 000 right so the new hampshire
army national guard is 1700 soldiers and
1100 airmen
those seventeen hundred soldiers when
you're divided by our state's population
we're one of the smallest army national
guards per capita in the country
there's two leverage you get to
influence one is accessions getting the
new kids in on the street and the other
one is retention
in this market
the accessions is horrendous for the
entire department of defense
if you look what's going on and so i
sent out some attachments i just see
some recent articles about
how the department of defense is
struggling to fill their formations the
active duty army cut their end strength
the number of people in their formations
by 12 000 because they know they can't
make their numbers this year the air
forces come on and says they can't make
their numbers and it's the same thing in
the army national guard
so we struggle to fill our formations
it's like almost like a modern day
militia it's up to us to fill our
formations with those 1700 soldiers and
airmen
the market's just not there
so if you can't influence the sessions
you can try to retain your force the
retention piece this is a retention uh
measure and that's the purpose behind
this
so if we get a soldier to come in and he
enlists and he lists he typically has a
six year obligation at the end of six
years we're losing about 20 of our force
you know they finished their college
about 25 of our force joints for the
college benefit
so the purpose behind this bill is if
you re-enlist after six years of service
you can transfer that tuition waiver
benefit to your spouse
and allows your spouse to then attend
classes at the community college system
of new hampshire
community college system of new
hampshire supports it we work together
with them to develop this language
that's why it's a five-year
pilot program so we can see the benefits
uh or the impact it will have on the
community college system
but we are struggling to fill our
formations and if we can't fill them
with newest sessions off the street
these high school kids at age 18 we want
to try to retain our fours
in order to retain our force it's all
about the spouse that significant other
you in the next 12 months we'll deploy a
third of our force either overseas or
the southwest border
you know the strain or stressors that
places on a military family are huge and
like they're significant so if we can
retain the spouse to have an impact
on their significant other to stay in
the service it is money
subject well spent
thank you again for taking my question
um i was wondering
so in order for them to be
the members spouse to be eligible
they have to do a six-year tour of duty
correct
and then they have to do another four in
the reserves as well is that right
so that soldier or airmen will serve for
typically for their first initial
entry service contract in six years
if he or she re-enlists
beyond that six year like for another
four or six years in a national guard
only um then they he or she can transfer
to their spouse
okay um
yeah follow-up um
so after
they've served then the transfer becomes
effective correct yes
um
the question the second question i had
is at the bottom it says section for
this act
it's confusing but
the
if the past the legislation you know
will take
effect immediately or after the governor
signs it
but it's only good till july of 27
because the community college system of
new hampshire wanted to evaluate its
impact on their on their budget
so it's really it's it's good until july
of 27th
and then based upon that economic impact
to the community college system we'll
evaluate it and then hopefully renew it
for perpetuity
okay so it's after the passage of the
bill itself
it has a five-year
out date yes thank you
okay uh any other questions
uh representative
uh yes i'm representative lawton thanks
for taking my question
um so would this
basically if it gets past and the
governor signs it will it have an
immediate um benefit upon people that
have already
uh done six years or something like
could somebody use it like right away
yeah so for example if uh if you're a
service member you've been
hypothetically in for 10 years
you can then transfer to your spouse i
just want to clarify too it's in the
language that um it's one of the other
the service member of the spouse we're
not double dipping one person gets to
the other so if the service member says
you know i got my undergraduate degree
i'll now transfer to my spouse and it
has to be a spouse that's in the uh the
department of defense we call it dears
the the physical enrollment uh
enrollment system it just can't be
arbitrarily like a my significant other
it has to be a sort of registered spouse
within the department of defense uh
enrollment system
okay uh any other questions for the
general uh representative
thank you for taking my question uh
my question is why not expand it to also
children of uh national guard members as
well instead of just spouses
excellent question and so
i'll give an example the first state to
do this was pennsylvania they did about
two or three years ago and they did
exactly that they did it for both their
spouses and their children
we specifically said no to the children
the reason why is
80 of new recruits come from a military
family
so we want to cut off our nose and spot
of our face
so that's a next like what's their
incentive for those
kids to join
and so that's why we purposely excluded
uh military children
okay are there any representative
rollins
it's a reimbursement so it's just a
tuition waiver so no money ever sort of
uh transaction ever occurs between say
the university system of a community
college system and ourselves
a student a service member files a piece
of paper goes to that college
and they just waive the tuition you
still have to pay room and board and
fees
yeah general i'm not going to um i'm not
asking any questions or anything like
that because i'm a co-sponsor on this
here's
but anyways can you explain to him and
then i'm going to go back to skip for
follow-up on the space available that we
have now in law so they understand
what's there for national guard
yeah so initially um
it was previously written that it was on
a space available basis that if the
university system or community college
system had space availability um
they could um just attend that class for
that tuition waiver uh two years ago we
struck that from the law and the reason
why is um
the recruiting market is really
cutthroat
and we were losing market share to
massachusetts because they didn't have
that sort of space availability waiver
so all we're trying to do is make either
maintain our competitive advantage over
our sister states or in advantage
this gives us an advantage over our
sister states that we um you know about
thank you uh rep did you have another
uh sir can we had an airman get his law
degree through unh uh uh at manchester
unh uh
uh are there any other questions for the
general
seeing none thank you general for your
testimony thank you sir chair recognize
kevin grady with the state veterans
thank you mr chairman
ladies and gentlemen of the committee
good to see you again
for the record my name is kevin grady i
am a 25-year veteran of our air force
and i'm a
22-year resident of the town of hooksett
new hampshire today i'm here
representing the state veterans advisory
committee
we
debated this long and hard and talked
about it was one of the more lively
conversations we had and then we all
kind of realized that we need to get
behind a bill like this because we think
it's a win-win for new hampshire and the
re the way i'll explain that is if if in
fact we have somebody who has finished
their initial
tour of enlistment and the opportunities
are better somewhere else for their
spouse
or for themselves that's probably where
they're going to go
so
we we want to try and retain as many of
these people as we possibly can and if
it turns out that the
the spouse is really in a better
position perhaps to finish a degree
quicker and perhaps get a job in our
local economy faster that might allow us
to retain that that military person uh
as well
um the
the the way this program is set up every
year
the uh in november the uh adjutant
general is going to get a report from
the university system as to how many
people actually use this
benefit and so by doing this for the
three years the reason this thing sun
sets in in 2027 well five years i guess
now uh is that we're going to be able to
have a chance to look at this program
and see what the true cost is when this
was done in the in the senate the the
the university system was behind the
idea because the it's either the member
or the spouse that's eligible to use
this not both of them at the same time
so the the the a person attending a
class is a person sitting in a seat
attending a class whether that's the
member or the the spouse
doesn't really you know affect them all
of that much um the final thing that
i'll give you just try to bring this to
life a little bit in terms of the
retention part of all of this
for the general um
if i take somebody that and i'll let me
do what i know which is air force stuff
let's say we have an an airman who is a
uh is a boom operator on our kc 46 is
over at peas
if that person decides after their
initial six-year commitment to go ahead
and leave the military or maybe that
person decides that the benefits are
better in another state and they're
going to ziggy over there and take that
same benefit in another
state then we lose that person's
expertise and all the time and effort
and training that we throw into that
person now i general nicolitis can
assess another boom operator and we can
train that person and on paper
when we we're finished with that
transaction we got the same number of
boom operators that we had the other day
but as i like to say we traded away big
poppy for marv throneberry okay we
traded away somebody that that has a lot
of experience and and can pass that
experience on to our younger folks for
somebody who is going to have to be the
beneficiary of somebody else
transferring their experience to them so
we wholeheartedly support this bill and
subject to your questions really that's
all i want to tell you this morning okay
thank you kevin are there any uh
questions but kevin
c and none uh thank you kevin i'd like
to bring up general michaelitis back up
general can you explain to the committee
the difference between the so they
understand the yellow ribbon new gi bill
versus this program here and i'm not
asking a question so nobody gets
confused because i am a sponsor i
already know the answer but explain them
the difference is there a conflict is
there not
whereas if the gi bill you
you're getting paid money to go to
school and it can be shared with your uh
kids versus this here
so sir just correct me if i i think i
know where you're going um so say the
montgomery gi bill so what happens if
you go on active duty and you serve two
three four years ten years whatever you
if the federal government picks up the
tap for you to go to college in very
general terms
this is complementary
right so um
that is a federal uh
not entire uh it's a federal program
that only our soldiers who have either a
they had served on active duty initially
or b they were activated or deployed
they accrue that federal service time
and then can use that gi bill
this is more for the traditional sort of
so three two thirds or three quarters of
our force just
are part time
so of the 2 800 soldiers and airmen we
have in the new hampshire national guard
both army and air about 70 of them are
part-time
traditional soldiers and airmen who go
through the basic training come to us
serve their week in a month this is true
really for them i mean everyone can use
this but it's almost a complimentary
educational benefit versus a replacement
and then generally speaking you have to
use your montgomery gi bill first if you
have both before you use this
okay did everyone understand on that
system there because this really will
benefit the young soldiers coming in for
retention
you know i mean to maintain and be able
to re-enlist and stuff but
i don't see it being used a lot because
of the ones all the veterans that served
overseas
um their dependents could use that money
and the college systems are going to get
paid you know to the federal government
so think of it like this you know the
the data says most service members get
out at nine years
and what do they get out of nine years
so just let's just do some simple math
in a way say you join at 20 you're now
29 30 years old what happens when you're
30. you're most likely if you're
part-time with us you're establishing
your civilian job
and you're probably starting a family
and guess what those week in a month is
like sort of a drain on you you're like
you know what comes first my civilian
job or my part-time job what comes first
my family or going to my week in a month
so this is huge to retention so when we
talk about military families and what we
sort of do for the support of them you
know this is the enticement to say hey
your spouse can say
like hey dummy i i can go to school now.
and uh the secretary of the army came to
new hampshire about a year or two ago
and met the governor and one of his
lines or topics was the governor was sir
don't you understand the military is the
escalator to the middle class we're all
about education blue collar white collar
we're all about educational
opportunities
for building a better workforce and a
better citizen
that's the why thank you okay thank you
everyone understand uh
i brought that up so you understand the
breakdown of this here from coming from
the general there
okay i thank you general
uh are there anyone else out here that
wants to speak on this uh built
sp 360.
seeing none i'm going to go ahead and
close the hearing on this uh we are
going to exact this at 11 o'clock i have
two other reps that are coming back in
uh
representative loomis and mark pearson
are going to sit in for representative
dave lundgren and we'll execute it at
that time
so it shouldn't go it shouldn't be long
you know i may be real quick exactly
okay
uh one two three four five six seven
eight nine 10 11 12 13 good we have a
quorum
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session on sb 360. and um mr uh are you
ready with your paperwork and stuff too
right i believe i believe so okay
and i i believe uh representative moffat
you had a motion to make
thank you miss share yes i would like to
move otp ought to pass on sb 360. all
right thank you when the clerk second
that i heard you say i second okay
that's what i thought okay um thank you
uh would you like to speak to your
motion there representative moffatt
famous chair i simply like to say that
that this uh seems to be a
a very positive
recruiting retention
measure
that
the senate has sent to us
general mikulitis explained
in detail
how this would help
spouses male or female
to go back
and use this tuition waiver benefit to
take classes
so uh yes the recruitment retention
education uh all good in my view
awesome and anyone else want to speak on
i just had a question mr chairman right
here um about lack of a fiscal note is
it because the federal government's
going to cover the entire program
including administration well there
actually there's no money uh this is um
the these are seats that the colleges
are giving up
so there's no money coming from the
state okay so the state doesn't cover
any administration no because and
they're already because they're already
getting money from the budget okay so
that that's why there's no fiscal note
on this here
um
if um in the hearing era i mean i asked
the general there to explain to when
they're on the education on the
different programs that are out there
most in today's society where veterans
like he said most veterans uh and just
like in that society don't get married
for 10 years you know i mean until the
age 30 and matter of fact they're having
one or two kids if they're lucky
uh but the first six years many veterans
are single
uh a lot of veterans on active duty do
show up with young girls that are
pregnant
you know i mean in my time that i've
seen over and over that's why i spoke
out on the marriage thing you know i'm
protecting them young girls so they can
get the benefits to have kids and
everything but this hair bill is a
win-win
for more and more spouses whether it be
male or female of a veteran to get
educated and it just makes new hampshire
that much better and it retains
the uh national guard and national guard
uh to stay longer than just a six-year
program so they have to do another four
years so it's a win-win for us here so
yes
question um thank you mr chairman i was
just wondering what was the um what was
the rationale uh from the sponsors of
just limiting this to spouses and not
expanding it to children was it just to
see how the cost because if you give it
to the children there then why would
they want to join the military and get
you know and go to school for nothing
fair
uh that's the reason why the gi bill now
on the uh the uh
the yellow ribbon program that they
passed there
that they could be transferred to
children
if this if the veteran does not use it
so that one but you have to be deployed
to a war or uh you know
into another um either a base or
something for so many months or whatever
so
okay anything else on this bill
okay seeing that i'll ask the clerk to
take a roll call
representative moffatt i
represent
uh
representative rollins yes
representative delemus yes
representative
representative foster yes
aye
representative
i did
yeah i was looking at you i thought you
said marty
i better be careful
representative
epson thank you representative wilhelm
yes
sorry about this you guys i i just i had
yes representative
yes it would be appropriate for me to do
that
hurry up delemus we gotta get back to my
committee
okay 13-9 with any objection we put this
on the consent calendar
oh so be okay
i will close the hearing on sb the
executive session on sb 360.
and thank you to uh representative
pearson and
okay
um
he's already working on the um blurb
you know for the um
you